the last time brittany force visited the
strip at las vegas motor speedway she
took home
a wally and she's back this weekend and
will look to repeat at the denso spark
plugs
nhra 4 wide nationals yes mercedes
talked to her about her return take a
look
how much do you love las vegas oh vegas
has
always been one of my favorite tracks i
grew up at that racetrack as a kid
it's it's just a familiar racetrack for
me i drove
in super comp there a feel there i
actually part of my licensing in this
top fuel car
was in las vegas my first full pass ever
in a top fuel car
was at las vegas the strip at las vegas
motor speedway so it's a very special
place for me
and you know it's three hours down the
road from where i live so
you know growing up we do bachelorette
parties there and birthday parties there
so i
i love vegas i love the energy the vibe
that it puts off
and vegas has always been one of my
favorite race tracks on our circuit
and for years i've been saying i want to
win vegas and we did it in 2019
vegas 2. can you talk a little bit about
this track and a little bit about four
wide racing it's vegas and charlotte am
i right the only tracks that have that
yep correct uh vegas you know the four
wide it's
tricky it's um it's a whole new ball
game if there's not already enough going
on when you're up there staging
you know um staring at that christmas
tree
um worrying about going around like
there's already enough on your plate
that you're thinking about
and now you have three people in the
lane next to you
instead of just one so it's a lot going
on and
you have to know what lane you're in
where you are where you're looking
what bulb you're looking at and if you
get lost you're dead i've done it before
in charlotte actually the year we won
four wide
we rolled up there and everybody
pre-staged
and then we rolled into stage and
somebody wasn't staged
and me i just i'm the new guy out there
and i just thought oh my gosh crap it's
me
so then i went to go roll in the tree
came down i left a mile behind everybody
else
but the big thing was we went out the
next day that was q4 so i left
qualifying on just this sick feeling the
sick note completely screwed up cost our
team the run
and then we went out and we pulled it
together the next day
and and won the race and can we do uh
some rapid fire questions with you
yeah of course okay what's your favorite
fast food place and what do you order
i'd have to go with in and out in and
out and
on the east coast zach squeeze is my
all-time favorite
what song reminds you of your childhood
my sisters and i i don't know how this
just popped up in my head
used to sing uh johnny's angels i don't
know who sings it it's an
old old song but we used to sing
johnny's angels to my dad the legendary
jon force of course you gotta do that
what is the last show that you binged
the bachelor uh the bachelor and last
but not least what is the
one reason you got grounded as a kid uh
i went
camping when i was 16 um with a bunch of
friends and the cops busted us the next
morning because we weren't 18. best of
luck to you
we cannot wait to watch you race you are
really an inspiration we love
seeing you out there and go go brittany
thank you so much
an awesome weekend out there it's so
loud when you're out there and if you're
near the track there
you feel the the cars and your bones
that get so loud
the adrenaline what's the last thing you